the only kpop I know is sigh and Gangnam
style I know how to see squirrel I don't
expect I'm gonna do - well this would be
easier with like a shop pop - hyung I
didn't know if I was in his real name I
feel like everything's alive mm Hawk
Jason Hawk J son he's like that I'm
doing the sound that made it's like not
natural to English Park Shyam song
Pakistan it sounded right to me Oh
Taecyeon okay is that it's not okay
though
oh um one of these letters of salad okay
talk to you okay take yum-o
take on Oh tie up one I can't get my
head straight
a lot of times my mind will translate
attain this word subject oh tech young
and that's like probably not the way to
approach this at all I would just call
the person okay Kim Jong Hyun I would
have said shinny
it's shiny Kim jong-eun oh that's okay
oh we're doing a kpop star Kim Kim
jong-un Kim Jeong Joon it's another one
of those ages that sneaks in there Kim
Jong hey honey
Kim oh you kim jung-han I'm done Song Ji
Hoon rain rains a cool name one you hey
Jung Ji hun oh I was so far off John
Jimmy the J's are not J's joong-gu Shan
she choose Kim heat Oh Super Junior
that's like opposites
it's like fat skinny Super Junior Kim
Hee Kim Heechul like a Kim he shot me
John hmm that's the hardest thing I've
ever heard hey soo ji is bei bei or by
they soo ji o su Qi she said she I'm
used to saying like BAE as in like my
BAE but it's like bad let's try the
slower babe soo-ji I think that was good
we think it's pretty good it's not
pretty good that Quantium g-dragon
actually heard of this guy is pretty
popular Kwon ji-yong
yo yo Wan Jia oh yeah Hong I'm not even
gonna try that eat teddy 21 I know that
these these girls little girls right Lee
jae-hoon Lee cherry each island he carry
each hand in eat the salad oh that's
throwing me off park tenure EXO Oh
EXO Park Chanyeol oh no no I a let me
check it hard Jon y'all I don't hear the
ours being pronounced so it's like puck
Shawn you know Park Choong y'all oh that
last part so hard I literally can't hear
it's science I don't think I did very
well my lips weren't able to move like
they were supposed to I can't trust
anything or anyone anymore knowing that
size in his real name I hope I ended
nobody I think these are very pretty
name I apologize for butchering them you
know people pronounce my name what wrong
all the time
my name is Gary sighs my favorite
because I feel like he's just a key and
cool and that's why he appeals to people
I guess we all have a little bit of
weird in us